[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Laura Rutledge said to join us ESPN plus
exclusive coverage of the Broncos and
Jags Sunday morning they start at 9 30
a.m Eastern from London Steve Levy Dan
orlovsky Louis Riddick and Laura
Rutledge on the call and you can
subscribe to ESPN plus go to
espnplus.com or ESPN the app Laura
Rutledge the host of NFL live joins us
from London where are you right now
uh so I walked down the street from our
hotel trying to find a very London
looking background and it turns out I'm
in front of a Convent so that made me
laugh
you know I don't think I'll be joining
you today
um you still get that feeling when
you're there in London there's all these
jerseys from all these different teams
if you were going to describe the
feeling that you have NFL wise in London
like what's the vibe
they love it they're so excited to have
NFL games here I think the fandom
sometimes is underestimated from the
international fan but especially here in
London and I I really have run into a
lot of people who you know whether it's
been me talking about this game being on
ESPN plus between the Broncos and
jaguars or just sometimes people watch
NFL live over here so they've asked me
about the show I've been surprised at
the interest to be completely honest and
I think we are expecting a great turnout
at Wembley on Sunday I think they're
going to be even more excited as the NFL
continues to try to make sure its
imprint is felt uh internationally
do you have access to Russell Wilson
dude we're talking to him tomorrow okay
if I gave you one question
what are you asking
I think I want to ask him what's gone
wrong in his mind uh so far because so
much of his quotes and I think what
sometimes has turned people off this
year you know listen you can you can be
Russell Wilson the way that we know him
to be if you're winning a lot but I
think people would like for him to
acknowledge what's going on and where
there's a misconnect or a disconnect
between him and the coaching staff and
you know listen the way the NFL works we
know this quarterbacks and high paid
players don't necessarily take all the
blame when it comes to moving on from
them it's too difficult to do so it ends
up being the coaching staff that
shoulders a lot of that blame but I
would like to know and I will ask him
this question you know from his
standpoint why haven't they won more
games and and why has the offense looked
so incredibly stagnant and it's
difficult as you know that he's always
Mr positive it's rare when he gives you
a real answer I think when he gave me a
real answer uh after the Super Bowl a
couple of years ago that led to oh my
God there's something really going on
there and everybody was surprised that's
the frustrating part is you're trying to
get a real answer like how much does
this hurt that Seattle's doing well they
gave up so much to get you and and you
know but then how much do you press him
to go you know I want to get a real
answer out of you
I think you try and with him I mean as
you know I truly
saying this because I'm on your show I
think that your answer from him about
the his issues with the offensive line
and the front office that was one of the
first times we actually heard him break
stride from what we've known him to be
for all this time and so it's very rare
that he does that I don't know what she
did that day it must be because you're
an excellent interviewer but
um I I think that you know people would
love to see some of that wall broken
down and listen there are plenty of
people that love him the way that he is
those aren't the loudest voices right
now because he has struggled and because
this team has struggled but it's
fascinating it's it's a bit of a outside
of football fascinating case study in a
prominent figure who is struggling and
fails to realize maybe The Importance of
Being candid and a little bit more open
with the public but it feels like it's
open season on him
Seattle didn't want to keep him it it's
not it almost feels like the public
turned on him like yo you wanted out of
hey you got what you wanted but it feels
like even the subway commercials I mean
we're analyzing everything here Laura
yeah I think it's overboard I
I'm not immune to criticism
to whom much is given much is expected
and all the things but I I think it's a
bit overboard to me the personal attacks
are too much
um I just I don't see the need for that
but I realize that what happens in this
world is when you're really successful
and when you've had you know to your
point you've had the opportunity to go
get what you wanted Seattle said fine we
feel good about what we have and in fact
it's funny I was with them pre-season
and we actually felt like they were
overzealous in their praise for the team
that they had and for Geno Smith and
they didn't look great in preseason but
it's preseason right and so now seeing
their offense click the way that it is
and seeing them play so well we're kind
of like okay you know I think I think we
know why they felt good about moving on
um from Russ and that's not even a
slight at Russ I think it's more that
they felt good about who they had so to
me you know it does it goes back to I
get it you got to criticize the players
on the field and that's part of our jobs
but I do think some people have gone too
far in some of the personal attacks and
and I think that's affecting Russ too I
think he sees more of that then you
would expect him to see and it affects
him more and I'll be interested to ask
about that too when we meet with him
ahead of this game talking on Laura
Rutledge she's joining us outside of a
Convent that doesn't cleanse that
doesn't cleanse any of your sins just
letting you know
you guys help me out here like
wash me clean that that's not going to
help you in the big picture just letting
you know
um the Broncos Jag Sunday morning 9 30
a.m Eastern on ESPN plus Steve Levy Dan
orlovsky Louis Riddick Laura will be
there on the call and uh you can go to
ESPN plus if I gave Tom Brady or Russell
Wilson a do-over
oh
yeah I think they take it both of them
you think Brady would take a do-over and
just I stay retired yeah don't you think
he would and he would say let me just go
ahead and commit to TV let me uh you
know take the the personal side of it
out of there let it let him just say let
me kind of step into this next chapter
of life and and listen I mean in his
defense coming into this season and when
he thought he was coming back you know
he immediately calls his Center he says
let me make sure you're back he
assembles the team that he thought was
going to be a team that would have great
success especially in an NFC that you
looked at preseason you said ah who
knows maybe it's the AFC that's got more
of the talent and be more competitive
the NFC felt a little bit winnable kind
of still does you know outside of maybe
the NFC East but anyway you know and
then those guys start dropping like
flies and you you expect more out of the
Run game you think that Leonard
fournette is going to be more productive
you think you've got that the o-line to
protect him and and really he had been
so well protected there and they'd had
so much consistency on that old
consistency on that old line that I
think we kind of took for granted with
this Buccaneers team
um and you know the thing that had
shocked me as I thought Todd Bowles
would have a better handle on being a
head coach when it comes to the defense
too I'm sure Brady thought that as well
he's looking at this defense saying hey
you know this defense has been what's
carried them right and so uh I would
imagine knowing what he knows now he
would say wait a second let me not mess
around in that and I think we saw that
last night I mean I don't blame him he
looks he looks completely befuddled and
simultaneously incredibly frustrated by
what he's enduring right now The Story
of the Year in the NFL not Tom Brady off
the field but what is the number one
story to you
I think the number one story
to me is some of these veteran
quarterbacks we thought would have great
success going to different spots and not
doing well I mean who had Matt Ryan
being bitched for Sam Ellinger you know
things like that that we all kind of
looked around and said wow this movement
in the off season is crazy and we're
gonna see you know so many of these
teams that were so close the Colts being
a great example of that being contenders
but without a quarterback they're just
missing the quarterback so they finally
got one so they're going to be right up
there in the mix and then they bench
Matt Ryan and uh you know everyone's
talking about Frank reich's job security
and it to me those are things that I
didn't see coming so I I would say that
and and you know in turn kind of the
flip side of that story is is some of
these younger quarterbacks these
quarterbacks that are able to be dual
threaded Jalen hurts for example and
certainly the athleticism that we see
out of the Josh Allens and the Joe
Burrows and obviously the Patrick
Mahomes of the world just these wild
plays but also the ability to handle
these offenses so well uh these younger
quarterbacks are are ushering in a new
age and we've seen the beginnings of it
but I think this year might kind of put
a stamp on that with who we see in the
Super Bowl and who we see continue to
have success I'll leave you with this
very important question Thanksgiving
dinner you can only invite two so Dan
orlowsky Marcus Spears and Mina kimes
but one doesn't get invited
oh man that one's tough I'm Gonna Leave
Out Dan but it's not because I don't
like Dan Dan is like family to me but
he's so annoying with his food and his
lack of uh taste that I just I really
appreciate food and I and I would
probably be cooking Thanksgiving dinner
for my friends and so I would be
frustrated by having to make such bland
food to satisfy his remedial palette
I'm gonna go tell him I'm about to see
him I'm gonna go tell him that that I
left him out of Thanksgiving dinner he
won't be surprised
then he put ice cubes in red wine
you got the you got the group there and
all of a sudden
um you know he says Hey excuse me to the
waiter can I get a cup of ice and he
proceeds to then pour it into the wine
the police are coming uh-oh uh-oh
blasphemy toward wine I I think those
are the bad take police they're coming
after you exactly
um uh have fun over there great to visit
with you congrats on all your success
thank you Laura I appreciate it thanks
for having me it's Laura Rutledge from
the Mothership